strike outre-mer leur prix est allé chez
reste je voudrais tu seras est couvert
leurs coulisses des clous et c'est vrai
que hier énorme carton 1 pour vincent
lagaf 1,4 million de téléspectateurs
il est il est en tête des audiences hier
soir c'est fou franchement je vous dis
on s'y attendait on s'attendait pas du
tout à un tel carton benjamin castaldi
vous êtes sera écouté le format j'ai eu
la chance de découvrir avant j'adorais
le format veut pas dire donc je suis
préfère l'autre ont dépensé c'est
nouveau c'est une création française
n'est pas le temps de jeu que ça
français qui arrive à l'antenne
donc pour toutes ces raisons évidemment
je préfère strike géraldine maillet sais
même pas ce que c'est nouveau et que ces
français que c'est bien toi moi j'ai
détesté
j'ai trouvé ça alors attention je trouve
que évidemment la gardien lagaf a
beaucoup de talent évidemment c'est un
grand clown burlesque
le jeu était très très bien produit mais
moi j'ai jamais aimé la graph
j'aime pas la gaffe et j'aimerais
peut-être pas ces prochains ces
prochains les adore je trouve ça
complètement poussiéreux et complètement
ringard ces poètes pointe cme c'est
prout prout enfin j'en pouvais plus quoi
freiner que des onomatopées et même toi
là et je n'aime pas du tout et surtout
l'espace et là il ya un vrai souci c'est
en fait quand les choses qui est bien et
qu'elles qu'elles disent elles sont
vintage et quand elles sont pas bien
belle soeur un garde et la gêne que
c'est ringard
bon je suis pas du tout d'accord je ne
supporte plus la bobo géraldine maillet
oui hier vous avez pris une raclée mais
nos regards quiz je l'avais dit la série
beaucoup donné ces machines est en jeu
et c'est fini géraldine là vous pouvez
pas le nécessaire face à face mais lille
et toulon toute la soirée tout le temps
devant burger quiz des cas de la
concurrence ça s'effondre je revendique
cette énième salon mais pourquoi ils
sont toujours cela mais par sa victoire
ces inquiétudes ont panarina milanais
sur un lit j'ai l'impression d'être aux
présidentielles
je vais le finir géraldine merci la
grande télévision populaire qui les
tester c'était strike était une émission
remarquable pour tout public
ce n'était pas pas un nom qui sert tout
élitisme voilà les deux émissions sont
très bien chez dkny non mais burger quiz
a fait pas pareil à peu près pareil que
d'habitude un poil moins et c'est vrai
que strike à surperformer hier vous vous
ai préféré strike parce que c'est ça
votre style comics c'est parce que vous
avez joué par verdu c'est pas moi alors
moi j'ai adoré parce que d'abord je
compris c'est pas si fréquent de salles
c'est vrai donc je suis ravi
ensuite c'est vraiment la tête et les
jambes donc moi j'adorais un jeu qu'à
limoux j'adore franchement s'est trouvé
que c'était j'ai trouvé que c'était du
vent mais je comprends très bien ce que
tu dis mais moi j'ai vraiment beaucoup
aimé mais j'aurais pas été assez qu'on
doit accepter de participer à un jeu que
je trouverai des milles
donc voilà donc moi j'ai vraiment
vraiment beaucoup aimé j'y crois et
méfiez vous parce que tessa y croit
aussi